hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen blog
und ich erschrecke jetzt meine freunde
ich habe keine freundin
das frische von bloggern sieht irgendwie
so aus oder so oder so und dann gibt es
nicht ich esse ein brot mit nutella 1
mit frischkäse und trägt dazu ein glas
leitungswasser einigen tagen habe ich
dieses bild hier auf instagram gepostet
also ich mit einem schild auf dem
rettershof steht vor dem kölner dom und
das haben viele von euch gefordert hier
mal ein best-of es allerdings gerade auf
dem weg nach köln und ist in drei
minuten am bahnhof deswegen womit wir
testen heute den veganen bürger bei
mcdonald's weil ich in der seit einem
monat vegetarier ja dazu sagen ich nix
alter stelle folgt man dir sowie gab es
auch kein reis essen
da kann es weiterzumachen und kostenlose
in der reinigung hatten hier sind bei
mcdonald's angekommen was messe ist
lecker lecker was ist meine mutter sagte
immer zu wecken messen kommentierte
vorstellung visier haben die einen
vegetarischen burger
ja dann nehme ich habe zweimal den
billigen ts du wirst richtige ahlmann
der nette herr zweier dem und
kontrollieren sind kartoffeln sogar ein
theoretisches mal danke gleich jeder
mcdonald's riecht einfach gleich also
ich lasse jetzt den big vegan tsv
mcdonald's erich kuby jetzt veganen
sorgen die sache ist ich hab noch nie
was wie ganz zu meinem leben gegessen
[Musik]
die schmeckt reiter wie man abgestorbene
auflage ist gut also ich finde das ist
wirkliche alternative zu normalen
bürgern keine bezahlte werbung aber
schaut auf jeden fall der mcdonald's
nicht okay ich gebe dir 0,7 punkte von
dann nimmt jetzt eine mundharmonika in
den mund und ich schlage ihr gegen china
[Musik]
gerade runden und schneidet sich youtube
ich bin hier und ich weiß jetzt gleich
ein eimer gegen und steigert das die
ganze welt mit wasser steht hatten
stehen doch häufig fleisch andreas ohse
atem von ihrem volk und nach oben gerade
das jetzt erst mal eine rauchen muss
dies zu korrigieren
ich hab s abgebracht das hat gesagt hat
es gibt neue sachen war action
ja das ist ja die kennt vielleicht liebe
grüße ich als normale strohhalm größte
allerdings für sandra mit einer rolle
mal probieren zu trinken
luca ist alles heute wieder von einer 10
eine neue auto sieht eine pizza hut
nummer vier gehen
du kannst nicht dreimal um dann auf
gegen den schrank und jetzt läuft gegen
frankreich war auf toilette bei mir in
der wohnung und komme so raus und sie
hört dass sandra mit der rauschbrille
auf ein paar fußballschuhe
wir sind nicht reden nein bedienen doch
wie lange schaut ist der donnerstag und
am donnerstag kommt ja auch mal eine
neue folge große der beschreibung ist
auch link online und wir nehmen diese
folge jetzt auf bevor wir die alternativ
auf den machen ein bisschen sport um
reinzukommen
wenn jetzt gerade drei stunden lang
videos aufgenommen podcast folgen
aufgenommen instagram bilder für sandra
aufgenommen was machen wir jetzt
ich muss nach hause ich habe burnout so
sieht es übrigens aus wenn man mit
sandra eine podcast folge aufgenommen
habe ich übrigens so normal einfach
schnell gehe ist das besondere einfach
joggen
ja wie gesagt ich habe genau welche
neurose wagen dann schlafen so aufstehen
wieder
ich habe seit vier tagen nur probleme
mit meinem internet
ich will champions league kommen das ist
lego mit einem ladekran in der mitte
wird spart sich schneider bei der augen
tränen gesagt was jetzt der blogger
heute allerdings auch wieder vorbei
meine lieben freunde wenn es euch
gefallen hat dass ich mal wieder
geblockt habe dann lasse gerne einen
daumen hoch unter dem video da und ich
beende das ganze jetzt mit einem witz
was hat 20 beine und kann fliegen zehn
vögel
[Musik]